Look Who's Back are we on yes we're on
how are you Patrick
I'm doing well Mark yes you are you look
different you sound different
everything's different about you
thank God
um
I was thinking uh
it's been almost exactly two years
since our first interview
you were a different person that first
interview
yeah I mean I think like the first one
was the one right
um that was the craziest one right
or the second craziest one well I don't
know if that was the craziest one yeah
you gotta look crazy that was like the
first week and then I think we we
chronicled that right up to like the end
of the second one more than anyone I've
interviewed
you laid it all out I mean you aired
your dirty laundry for everyone to see
yeah
that's interesting maybe we can start
talking like
um I still remember
like being out there right right out
here
before that and um
like wondering if this was even real you
know because it seems like we were out
there for a while and I was with people
that were you know getting high when
that had no money and
literally it was like because this was
not your typical stomping grounds
it was more Figueroa Street no I mean
I've been around here plenty too
um but just the fact that yeah you're
gonna go in here and do this interview
and then the fact that you the fact that
you knew who I was and that you wanted
me to come to the interview I was still
thinking that maybe the people are you
aware of my channel
I had I hadn't discovered it that very
morning
okay with Amber with a girl you know a
girl that I was hanging out with that
you had interviewed her and uh and she's
like you want you want to do an
interview today and I was like yeah
whatever
and then I wound up here you know
because she told me to be here at a
certain time and still I was thinking
maybe she was just trying to scam me no
Edwards brought me a lot of great people
yeah Amber's a great friend so I know
that you know
um but at that time I was out of my mind
and uh but but the part that the reason
why I bring it up is I remember coming
in here and just something inside me
saying screw it like
just do it you know and uh you mentioned
I don't know like if there was something
of a cry for helping that I think I I
remember we talked about during that
first one
uh that uh let's get wrong
um
the idea that people would maybe stay
sober after talking about it like that I
don't know the whole thing is just
you know it was it maybe kind of it it I
think overall it's affected me in a good
way you know like I discovered for the
first time in my life
um
that
like people still love me a lot of
people love me even more knowing
everything you know that's the one thing
I've seen yeah you know Common Sense
would tell you to not go public with all
this humiliating embarrassing crap
you've gotten into
right but what I've learned is when
somebody airs all their embarrassing
stuff that they have gotten into
that the reaction from the viewers
from the world is that this person needs
our help or
deserves our compassion yeah rather than
if you're hiding it
you can kind of sense that right you
don't know necessarily what they're
hiding yeah you don't know what they're
hiding and you don't know who they are
you know and and you can sense that
they're not divulging everything and I
think addiction
more than anything or you know I think
if in in with addiction the disease of
addiction like that brutal honesty is
you know like crucial to overcoming and
so like accepting myself
as you know like I have this thing you
know I'm an addict
um
and that's it like take it or leave it
and it was like the beginning of like
the end and I don't know if it's ever
the end end because it always sort of
like the ego always rebuilds and there's
always going to be a sense of like uh
caring what people think but it's so so
much less than it was before
um
where I was trying to be two people you
know and I was trying to pretend
like I was just like a normal person and
I would never want certain people in
certain areas of my life like work for
example to know
um
so yeah and but then it also there was a
period of time where
I mean I know that part of part of my
deal and I think it's I'm probably not
the only one that's that's
you know in addiction or recovery or
whatever
um part of addiction I think is I have a
brain that
uh is very susceptible to believing
delusional untrue things right
like that's part of the deal you know
like like the disease is in my brain
um and
part of my particular delusion when it
comes to like this experience you know
because I did all those videos and then
there was then they were they were
popular and there was a ton of comments
and uh
I was thinking for a while there like
especially when I remember when I went
to the east coast for a few months
I was thinking like oh you know like God
put this whole thing together and I'm
going to be like famous I'm going to be
like famous as like through this and
make money and and save the world right
like I was thinking that I was even
thinking oh my gosh like uh you know we
I had the idea in my head that maybe I
would like
get a car or something and like drive
back across the country from from Boston
stopping at places along the way where
fans would be and like
and do my own YouTube channel and uh
yeah I don't know man
um
we all get caught up in that little
thought that was
it was yeah that was weird you know it's
just like weird if I think about some of
the stuff I would think
um
yeah but anyway it's been a while now
you know I think the last time I was
here was uh over a year ago
I get a lot of emails yeah what's going
on with Patrick yeah yeah there's a
there's a there's a Reddit uh thread out
there you know about that there's a
there's a soft white underbelly Reddit
thread okay I can imagine what's on
there yeah actually it's that's all
right a lot of different topics and uh
and then so when I just so so you know I
did make some friends like I did I did
like meet people through this like not
too many a handful and uh most of them I
think only one person I've met through
this that I actually met in person but a
few others that I uh were am friends
with I'd say like
through text and uh or email or whatever
and uh one of them
um reached out to me
and she was really happy when I
responded because there was a the rumor
that I was dead on the Reddit or
somewhere in the comments or something
and she's the one that told me about
this Reddit thing and so I went to it
and that was fascinating it's like I
like went through the whole thing
looking for me you know and there's a
couple there's a couple little little
not they weren't too extensive but
topics that were like about me
specifically
and then I was dead and then I responded
to a couple of them and you know when
you respond uh people be like I don't
believe it's you all right like since
I've been so I'm sober obviously
um I've been sober for a little over
nine months right now how'd you do it
um through yeah
yeah so I'm in a 12-step program that's
like the foundation of my life
um but I've been in 12-step program you
know for years
um
it got really bad you know I was here
in September of what year are we 22 now
21
I think I was playing in a golf
tournament the day after that and uh
we didn't qualify it was a qualifier and
I remember like on the 11th T we were
playing terrible
and I said because I already I always
had it in my head I don't know if I came
out and said it like totally honestly
but I was gonna get high again for sure
that was the plan and uh I think you
said that didn't know when I had you
know I was like sort of like trying to
stockpile
free time and set it up you know
but then when because if we qualify for
that tournament then the tournament
itself which we had won in the past so
it's it mattered to me it was going to
be like three or four weeks later
and so I think I had it in my head like
not like you can plan these things out
really but
to my own to the best of my planning at
that time
to maybe get high after the tournament
but then when we weren't going to
qualify I would seemed like for sure we
weren't I decided I'm doing it tonight
you know I'm doing it tonight on the
11th T and then we go on a run and like
play really good and get to the like the
18th hole of where we're right on the
edge of qualifying right on the edge and
we didn't and so then I went and I I
went on another you know I got high some
more so you were playing after getting
high
no no we we didn't qualify for the
tournament so the golf thing was was
done and then you did and that night you
know I I got high for
I can't remember the details of that uh
the one thing I do remember about coming
back out here and getting high again
um was I I ran into the guy who jumped
me remember the guy who jumped yeah you
know you got wrong I don't know if I
should say his name on here
it's not his real name probably no it's
not yeah but uh yeah so like I I came in
here and did an interview right after
getting jumped over here right
actually just drove by to hear the show
my friend that came to me
um so now I'm down here again you know
right over here for however long a few
days and uh
I was interacting with people that are
in the circle of that same guy and
he next thing you know he's like I think
I was in someone's tent or whatever one
of the bigger one like it's like a and
uh he was there
and we sort of we realized I think I'm
sure he knew it was me and
but it was beautiful because
he like apologized and I like forgave
him
and we were cool that's great you know
and uh I could it was meaningful to me
and I I don't think he was I don't think
he was bsing me like it was meaningful
to both of us he felt bad you know well
he's just trying to survive exactly I
from right right from after that like
you were a Target yeah I get it like you
almost have to do that you know if I I
would sure I would have done the same
thing if I could well you know and so I
we so we were able to do that we were
able to like shake hands and and
be friends to whatever extent you know
and that was cool and things like that
are are
pretty cool
um
anyhow
I sobered up for not very long at all
um
like in November October November
the last of that year and then uh
went back to work
after being off for like 10 months
you're still at the same job I am after
all this time
but a great boss you've got build that
job yeah like it's it's a blessing and
um
I know there's been a lot of comments
about like how could that how could uh
how could I still have that job and I
don't disagree you know uh
I don't deserve it
um
you know and and
I I don't know for a fact I mean I do
know for a fact in some cases but I'm
just under I just assume that everybody
there knows about this now like they've
all seen the videos now it gets around
and I've talked to people directly about
it and uh and I'm cool with that too
like that's probably good you know
but I did
uh relapse again one more time after
going back to work
um
and it was the worst one of all like
like as far as like I was just so
I don't know how close I was to actually
dying but that's I really wanted to like
more than ever now there's a lot of
crack addicts that are done I really
wanted you know I did have that fentanyl
overdose you know that we've already
talked about here
um
but like January February and into the
beginning of March
um
you know I at this time you know I I had
you know I lost my apartment in the
beginning of you know like that first
couple months where we were doing the
videos that's where I lost my apartment
so I didn't have an apartment
ever since way back then so I didn't
really even have a place to live you
know went back East came back here I was
like standing with my mom and I moved
into a sober living house I was living
in a sober living house when I had that
final relapse and uh
so you get kicked out there those aren't
it's not like my apartment that's just
sitting empty I'm having a sober house
and I don't come home and then you know
they box up all your stuff and that's it
so
I didn't have a place to live you know
and I'm I'm uh
you know I got a storage unit you know I
remember
um
like having a bunch of boxes in my car
and I'm on the streets in Pomona
um
just so done you know didn't care about
anything I was uh
you know doing crack and meth and uh
started discovered angel dust PCP uh
which is just
like that's a whole nother
thing I I didn't do that much but at the
very end I was doing that it just puts
you completely the way it's like it's
like you're it's like your brain it's
almost like I feel like my brain is
turning into liquid and like draining
out
you know just I thought it was I thought
I was dying like it was you just have
these
uh
just hallucinations and
just hope to die you know I I was a
I remember I was in Pomona and the one
thing about it too and this has always
been true about my using is that I never
wanted to I never want to go to sleep
like I never want you know like maybe
it's been four days and I'm so tired
it's like give me some let me find some
drugs so that I could stay awake because
I think I don't want to
because it's like fantasy right it's
like my life
I'm
I'm a death wish you know suicidal sort
of State
but
I'm numb and it's fantasy and it's not
real and once I sleep and wake up then
it's then it really the reality of it
hits me I think
um you know my girlfriend found me like
laying unconscious on the sidewalk in
Pomona one day you know
and I vaguely remember you know you know
she's little you know trying to like
Lift Me Up get me into her car
so that's kind of like how I was living
you know in March you know and I think I
hit you up for money you know a couple
times there you like left with 20 bucks
whatever anything uh so I could keep it
going
um I was crazy man
and somehow I wound up in rehab I have a
lot of people who love me grateful for
that a lot of that
um
came from you know like the majority of
my friends really other than family uh
is from the program so from going to
meetings for how all those years I very
a bunch of very close friends and one of
my
one of my closest friends an older guy
named Steve he's like family to me
um and he he has he has the attitude
that a lot of people have the attitude
that I hope to have and continue to have
which is I'll do anything to help you
unconditional I don't care how many
times you I don't know how many times
you blow it
and uh is that what's required
with a drug addict who's just repeatedly
self-destructing
to have just an unlimited amount
of forgiveness and understanding
and patience
um because a lot of families are just
like enough of this I don't know that
it's tough love well
not from the family necessarily no I
don't I don't think this is my opinion
here so not that I not that this is for
sure true I don't know that that's
required but I I do believe that that's
available maybe not from the family you
know like I do have that for my family
which I'm really grateful for
um but people in the program like
like I will hope and I like that's how I
feel right now that if I'm helping
someone like someone that's in that
position that I will always be like that
with whoever
and I've found that the people in the
program like my friend Steve that I'm
mentioning here or there's a lot of
people like this like Flavio came with
me today
um
that they will be like that towards me
because that's part of my recovery like
the people that have been there and and
gotten clean themselves
we understand how could I ever um
you know like
tell somebody okay enough's enough I'm
not going to help you anymore you know
like like that unconditional love and
stuff is that is part of the deal that
is part of the uh
of the recovery Community is that we we
could we we always believe you know like
I like if I can get it you know and not
that I've arrived you know I'm still in
the beginning but if any some of us that
have been some of our stories are so
crazy and if
if any of us can get it all of us can
anybody can get it you know
but what happened with me is I wound up
on Steve's couch because like that was
part of uh that's part of his
relationship and his his approach is
like you know you could stay on my couch
and uh you know like what I should have
been doing
was like trying to get into a program
right you could always try to get into a
program like anybody can I think try to
get into a program somehow
but I was literally so out of it and so
just like depressed and physically
hammered and tired that what I wound up
doing was not that what I wound up doing
was like laying on Steve's couch and and
like when he asked me is it cool if I
call programs for you saying yes right
and so he did and he wound up dropping
me off at one
um
and uh it was like this is residential
little rehab and um
I remember I was there
and I had gone back to work and then I
had missed like I don't know a few weeks
now of work but I but I
you know I had vacation time or whatever
like I was still getting paychecks every
two weeks you know I would always get
paychecks every two weeks for a few
Cycles or a couple Cycles I remember I
was at that place
and then payday came right because
that's the thing like like I'm what I'm
using it's like I spent all the money
you know when I get more money that's
what I do with it and so I remember I
was at that place when more money came
and I remember like
I lasted like about a day before I
told them the truth you know like hey
I'm leaving you know and there's there's
this girl working there she's real I
stay in touch with her she's a great
like she I
she had a really good sort of style of
helping people and um
she was the one there as I was packing
up my stuff and we both knew what I was
doing I was straightforward with her and
she got it she understood you know
and I got an Uber and ubered back down
to Pomona and got high
you know for a couple more days and then
when I'm going back into that place and
uh
and but then my time there ran out and
then they transferred me to another
program that had a sober living house
sort of like relationships that I I had
a bed in a sober living house and a spot
in a rehab program
on the other side of town out by LAX
and uh
so depressed all I wanted to do was
sleep
so I remember sleeping in the car the
whole way there going through the
check-in like this isn't gonna work you
know go going into this this house
and uh it was the two it it was two
weeks later because it like occurred to
me oh I'm getting paid tonight you know
I think it was gonna be the last money
that was going to come in
and I'm over in Westchester
um which is like you know where that is
right so it's like by the airport it's
like a
it's kind of easy to get from
Westchester to South Central oh yeah
without a car you know there's like
there's like boulevards that run right
there it's already like okay here's what
I'm doing like uh
I gotta just wake up at like two in the
morning or whatever and just go go to an
ATM and go and that was my plan
um
but this house they they uh they sort of
forced us all to go to a 12-step meeting
that night you know so
okay whatever right it's walking
distance I walk down the street and uh I
sit through this meeting and I've been
in hundreds if not thousands of meetings
so I you know I know the drill
um
that didn't look good I think I probably
had like 10 days sober at that time just
physically physically sober
which I was trying to sleep away you
know
and they have a thing at some of these
meetings where they all ask like does
anybody call it burning desire like does
anybody
does anybody feel like if like like they
really want to get you know drink or use
or hurt themselves like now's the time
to talk about it
and I thought like well yeah I was
thinking of myself I do and I'm gonna
like why not why not
do the thing like why not say it like
this is the time for that I've never
done that before because I never felt
like I I never felt like that I'd never
been in a meeting where they asked that
question and felt like the answer was
yes
so I raised my hand and I I talked about
it you know I told them
yeah you know it was like
all I wanted you know like this sucks
all I want to do is get high you know
and that's what my plan is to do tonight
and um you know what I really wished I
had and I'd mention this to them
is I wished that I had the desire to be
clean but I didn't you know like that
would have been nice
anyway I said that and it was sort of
like people still remember that to this
day like I still go to that same meeting
like every like I literally haven't
missed a week
but that night you know I literally had
been living in this house for like three
hours so I hadn't even slept there for
one night yet when that first night
happened and
and I walked back to the house and that
was sort of like an icebreaker moment
for some of the dudes that were there
that I didn't know at all and and uh
I went to sleep and like forgot to wake
up I guess or slept through the night
and I woke up in the morning and I
had something of a desire to be sober
that next morning
um but I so this is my long I I realize
I answered questions in a really
long-winded way like you asked how did
how did you do it and uh I don't really
feel like I did it you know
um
like I didn't really
I don't think it's I don't think it's
possible for me to create my own
surrender like I woke up the next
morning feeling different I can't really
take credit for that
um but I also was in a position in my
life that now at that point where I was
grateful not to like be compelled to go
get high but I had nothing going for me
like like in a traditional sense you
know like it was
I had
I had been so destroyed by this thing
now
I didn't really care anymore
um in a in a deeper way than I had ever
felt before
I had nothing left to hold on to
um
you know when people when a lot of guys
come into programs or get sober it's
like
they want we because I'm in the same
boat we want like the things of life to
build back up as quick as possible like
get on get my own place get a girl get a
car you know what I mean get back in uh
and I had already like experienced
getting those things back and and uh I
didn't care about that sort of stuff uh
I didn't know if I had a job anymore and
I didn't really care about that either
um and that's the truth like
uh one thing I one thing I
discovered or I know that I believe is
that
if I'm sober it doesn't matter if I have
that job or any specific particular job
because if I don't I'll just get another
one and if I'm
getting high
then it doesn't matter like I'm not
gonna you know I'm Gonna Keep it yeah so
the job so that doesn't matter
so anyway I was in this I was sort of in
this state and in the beginning it was
really like
really clear to me that uh
it was almost like I it was almost like
I was in Extra Innings like I was in a
really good peaceful
mood you know and I would I would uh I
was living in a house with a bunch of
younger guys a lot of guys that were you
know struggling with even like a lot of
guys that probably didn't even want to
be sober at all and I understood that
you know like I'm like the I'm like the
old man now you know when I started
trying to get sober and going to rehabs
when I was in my early 20s
now I'm in my 40s I've been I've had so
many of these experiences and so I had a
really good experience there with those
guys sort of being like a big brother
or an uncle you know I did a lot of
dishes and uh
helping those guys out but I would just
like get up in the morning and like get
in the van and go to rehab and then come
back and it's like I didn't learn
anything new at rehab I've been there
you know but just my attitude got better
and better and as I was trying to help
other people and just go with it and uh
and then I come home at night and I go
to one of the meetings and um
I would go to the same meetings every
week which I still do to this day and
you know I it's just it's like simple
formula like anyone that's really made
any sort of an effort to get sober in
12-step
sort of environment
you know knows it knows what they tell
you to do
go to meetings get commitments you know
get like be of service at the meetings
volunteer to do stuff against what they
call sponsor they go through the and
actually go through and do the 12 steps
um helping others seems to be a huge
component in this Alabama is probably
the most important thing right
um honesty is helpful
yeah yeah and the self-worth you'll need
is important yeah my honesty you know
and people like if like if they find out
about these videos and that just kind of
gives I mean like I I guess I in like
the rehab world or especially like in
the hardcore drug world like of the of
the dudes and like
there's like a there's like a certain
level of like respect and people at
first see me like there's a couple guys
at this at this particular program I'm
good friends with a few people that I
went through there with cool cool people
but different backgrounds a lot of like
sort of harder core upbringings game you
know gang type stuff like like hardcore
dudes right that got caught up in drugs
and and more than one person has told me
like when they first see me they figure
oh I'm not gonna talk to that guy that
guy's like a he's probably like an
alcoholic uh you know that got caught at
work at his corporate job and then they
hear my story or if they happen to watch
Like the First video then they're like
oh wow you're the real deal and there's
like a there's like a level of
connection you know like a level of like
sort of
this guy gets it respect like we could
talk about like we could talk about like
hookers and crack and meth and heroin
you know uh
so that's you're like I'm proud of it
but
um
so I don't know what to say other than
that like I was brought to a place of
surrender the deeper than ever different
than ever right and and uh like I had
like you know what did that uh drugs and
alcohol did that not not me
and at that place of surrender
uh I believe that I was able to
find a connection with like a spiritual
connection with God or however you want
to word it
um like I've been able so far to
do a somewhat good job of maintaining
that I don't think I don't believe that
we can create it but I believe that once
it comes that we there's things that we
can do to maintain it
uh and that and at the host the 12-step
program is like tailor-made for that
and there's a lot of there's there's
some sort of personal work involved in
going through that process of of kind of
like doing some writing and listing you
know
um like resentments and like pretty much
like opening up your whole self you know
seeing some of the ways you tick
but then continuing to go continue to be
of service and continuing to know that
like I have a brain that has proven
for Reuben that it always goes back to
the first crack hit like I've never I've
never ended I'm never getting myself
into the position where like I can trust
my brain
right and that's that's been a
particularly difficult thing for me
because in a lot of other areas of life
like trusting my brain has proven to be
like the way to solve problems
applying that to this
has literally made it last 20 years and
get worse and worse and worse you know
for this problem
like to the best of my ability what I
need to do is
is try to put myself in a in like a a
position of openness to outside help
spiritual help to the direction from
others direction from others that I
probably wouldn't want to take
directions for in a lot of areas you
know but just like doing that
uh
and like I haven't had the desire to get
high
you know I have not had the desire to
get high one time in the last nine
months which that's that's what I need I
don't like I don't like there's no way
of describing to you what that feels
like you know
I can't I don't think I can I don't
think I can go through life
like with some like method of resisting
if that comes that Obsession what I need
is for it not to come
and my experience and what I believe is
happening is that like like the
surrender thing that happened to me and
then like continuing to stay in it like
I've like like I'm doing it has a
something about that it's kind of it's I
don't know exactly how it works but
something about that keeps it away keeps
the obsession away
um
and your self-worth increases as you do
it yeah oh for sure
and protects you from falling back into
it yeah like uh and and then being able
to just to be myself to be honest like
I'm not perfect like I do a bunch of
stuff you know but but I pretty much
always honest about it you know and uh
I remember when uh
remember when I came in here a couple
times I think I did a couple videos like
physically sober but not you know not
yeah you were not recovering or
not really recovering and it was really
hard
like there was a big fear of being
honest you know like the like the crack
and being high is like a like truth
serum yeah like screw it yeah here we go
um but then coming in here without that
it was hard you know like I was I was
afraid uh but I do not feel afraid right
now you know what I mean like it's
it's peaceful it's it's sweet
so it's wonderful yeah and I stayed in
that area so like I
uh
I was I had such a good experience and I
was plugged into that that Fellowship
that particular local Fellowship there
um
that when my time at that program was up
because I had Insurance you know
um I saw some come out yeah sometimes
it's like I see comments and I wanted to
defend myself against them but like one
of them was like like oh this guy's
parents paid for so many rehabs my
parents haven't paid any money for me
for any of the rehabs I went to but I
had Insurance in it and then they they
pretty much dictate when the program's
over
and at that point I uh I was able to
stay in that area like I was able to get
a little Studio
literally a five minute walk from that
that sort of living house
in Westchester I still live there today
although I need to move out that's total
sidebar thing the landlord needs to
remodel it but
um and so I'm still going to in that
same sort of routine you know same sort
of routine uh yeah yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
um that's a good question
I usually don't know what's best for me
and same sort of idea from another angle
what I often what I think is best for me
Isn't
and God's real man
just went out of given up hope
I got another chance to be alive and it
was different
you know right around my birthday my
birthday's in February
so last year February would have been
towards the tail end of that last using
spell where it was like mentally and
emotionally was like by far the Bottom
by far
and
I was in a hotel room I didn't have a
place to live you know and I hadn't
really seen anybody I was just there by
myself just wanting to either like take
another crackhead somehow or die I
remember my dad found out where I was
and came
and I love my dad man he's like probably
my best friend
like I love him he loves me too but he
basically came there and
in a way I don't know that doesn't sound
morbid or weird but I understood what he
meant does he like gave me permission to
die
he came in there and he told me he
understands
you know like it must be so awful to
deal with this and I was like yeah that
was sort of like the way I looked at
dying was like a total relief from this
life
and uh you know I would I would tell him
I'll tell him I wouldn't really tell
anybody else this like this sort of
thing but like
like you know when I die and everyone's
really sad and I know you're going to be
sad I'm sorry
but I want you to realize and be happy
for me
you know and he understood that
something with my relationship with him
and but he came in there and told me
like he's like you know you kill
yourself or whatever it's like I I get
it you know
um so it was kind of a deep moment
and my response to that although I heard
it and I remember it now it just comes
to mind but my immediate response for
that that deep father-son moment was to
ask him for 20 bucks
so that I could get some more crack
you know which he didn't give me
yeah it's so hard for the families yeah
yeah
um
so yeah like uh
gotta stay humble
gotta do my best to stay honest I still
do believe that this experience with you
and this whole thing
um
that
like I discovered or we discovered the
the power of brutal of brutal honesty in
that
again there's some sort of like like uh
lesson or something that others can
can get from this
um
or that that that we can use when we try
to help people that are that are that
are getting sober themselves is to
encourage that Honesty the full-on 100
here's everything kind of honesty that
helps like there's a power in that it
takes a load off your shoulders right
there's great power on that there's
great connection in that and and
acceptance you know of you know this is
me like I'm capable of some of the most
like I used to I always used to have
like flashbacks of like some of those
things I did you know I would really
be so disgusted with myself especially
with the uh like abdicating all
responsibility for self-support like
here I have it doesn't matter how much
money it is you know like I'm a I'm a
grown-up
in America that and part of the deal
being a group in America is you support
yourself right you have a place to live
and and especially if you have I I don't
happen to have kids or anything
and
to take that and then just go and like
spend all the money on drugs and hookers
and and that crap and get myself to the
point where I have nothing
and then I would get sober again and
maybe like I somehow I think of this at
work like I picture myself at work and
then remembering that and just being
like wincing like
um
and no not anymore you know like part of
the acceptance like that's that's what
we're dealing with that's what we're
dealing with and so that helps me to
continue to to the best of my ability I
have good days and bad days as far as
you know being like humble and thinking
of others ahead of myself you know
um I recently got
somebody asked me to sponsor them in a
12-step program which I mean I'm at the
beginning stage of like that part
um
so that and then like another thing
um
I recently got engaged
yeah
and so
um like the other day congratulations
thanks
um you know I've had a there's been this
my girl all these years like the whole
time you know that I've been here
in fact this week is funny like this
week's like two years since the first
you know seven years since I met Nancy
and uh we dated in the beginning and
then we sort of broke up and we she
always stayed in my life and we always
were friends she always loved me you
know and she was always there
especially when I was at my worst at
your worst shoes always she was there
always she was there and I kept on
thinking I didn't want that you know and
everyone that I know all the people that
are closest to me have been telling me
for years like marry her
like she's the best and uh I don't know
what was wrong with me like I like when
I say I don't always know what's best
for me like that is a
um it's not just you a lot of people do
this she's off she's perfect like uh I
told her I was going to talk about her
um you know I told her I talked to her
this morning and I said should I invite
everybody to the wedding you know like
all the all the people and she said no
you can't afford it it'd be funny uh
but um
there was a moment
where I realized that I'm in love with
Nancy or how much I love her
um I don't know why
it happened the way it did but it was
back
last year in between like around like
the after the time I did that last video
here and I was back and forth living
that like staying with my mom and Havasu
and there was this one you know there
was a couple times where I was in lake
house here Arizona and I with the itch
to get high and so I took off you know
cruising around Lake Havasu looking for
crack which is you can't find it it's
not there
but there was one time where I did a
bunch of meth with the people there
so I did so much uh
that I came back to my mother's and
couldn't sleep for like two days I was
just awake
and I was always in touch with Nancy and
and uh
anyway there was this one conversation
phone conversation we had where we we
literally I'm not very it's not like I
just you know when you meet a girl
sometimes you'll have these Marathon
phone conversations like I've already
known her for five years right and we
had a we had a conversation that was
literally longer than eight hours on the
phone like like you know how the phone
has a timer
oh
where we just told each other everything
and I loved her so much after that I
don't know what I don't know what it was
about that or how my eyes were open
there
um
and uh
everyone loves Nancy
she's just
she's stuck by you through the toughest
points of your life he's like my angel
um
she loves me
She Believes In Me you know she always
has had like a no judgment type of
attitude towards the towards the drug
thing
um it's been hard for her like I put her
through it I mean she's she's seen the
more than any person that doesn't get
high themselves she's seen way more
she's seen me doing all the things I do
when I'm out there
um
and then like I feel like our
relationship has really gotten
um even better
recently like since the summer for you
know like in these last months and like
when I'm around her like we just
it's great you know we like we enjoy the
same things we never judge you when you
were making your big mistakes no no no
not at all she just wanted she just
wanted me to be okay you know she knows
all of it sex stuff all of it you know
and she kind of understand I mean to as
far as someone that isn't an addict
himself can understand she understands
but it's like um
it's like she sees me uh
like for
like what the what I what I could be if
I was good you know like she sees it's
like she sees me for what I would be
without the drugs and alcohol like if
only the good part of me was expressing
itself
um that's love
yeah you know and when and we're not
getting any younger we're both in our
40s and uh you know I was able to do it
like I've never done this before uh like
I got a ring and asked a girl to marry
me and she said yes and now we're super
excited I'm even more excited like it's
beautiful and uh but anyway like so with
with her with that happening and that's
very recent that was on Christmas
and then with my buddy that asked me to
sponsor him in the program
um
those two things are helping me right
now currently like this week uh
to not be okay with being as selfish as
I still am you know
because I tend to like
I tend to see like I've always my one of
the things one of the delusions my my
brain believes uh
historically is that like going and
getting high is like Freedom like that's
Freedom you know it's like I could do
whatever I want let's go
uh women just when it's the most
enslaving thing that a person can do
I might but I also like have these ways
of thinking like well now I'm free from
that and so now I can now I can like
quote unquote do whatever I want and I'm
like do whatever I want often looks
pretty selfish you know like no they're
not they're not all unhealthy things but
some of them are you know I'm obsessed
with playing poker I play poker all the
time uh
almost like obsessive type of person
golf or whatever but you know now I have
now I have a fiance you know and uh
hopefully we have kids you know and
and I haven't like a dude that's like
counting on me to help him in the
program and so these are motivating me
to be less selfish and to be more living
my life for others
which is good because I think that's
that enhances like what it takes you
know to stay to stay humble and sober
so
beautiful story
do you think people are gonna like this
as much as the other ones I think this
will probably be your
second most popular one okay
I love that first one for all the wrong
reasons it's good to see you mark
I'm proud of you good luck from here
all right Mark thanks